las calificaciones de un examen de
filosofía tienen una distribución normal
con una media de 40 puntos y una
desviación estándar de 3 puntos
louis obtuvo una calificación de 47.5 en
el examen cuál es la proporción de las
calificaciones del examen que son más
altas que la calificación de louis
escribe tu respuesta con cuatro cifras
decimales visualicemos lo que sucede
aquí las calificaciones tienen una
distribución normal así que lucen más o
menos así la media es 40 la desviación
estándar es 3 aquí está una desviación
estándar por encima de la media y aquí
está una desviación estándar por debajo
de la media aproximadamente aquí está el
43 y aquí está el 37
nos dicen que louis obtuvo una
calificación de 47.5 que estará más o
menos por aquí y nos preguntan cuál es
la proporción de las calificaciones del
examen que son más altas que la
calificación de louis lo que tenemos que
hacer es calcular cuál es esta área bajo
la curva de distribución normal la que
se encuentra por encima de 47.5 lo que
haremos para resolver esto es
el puntaje z de 47.5 cuántas
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media es esto después buscaremos este
puntaje en la tabla z para encontrar la
proporción que se encuentra por debajo
de esto recuerden que la tabla zeta nos
da las proporciones por debajo de un
puntaje z
después restamos esto a uno para
encontrar la proporción que está por
encima de esto recuerden que toda el
área bajo la curva es igual a 1 así que
podemos encontrar esta área que estoy
señalando y restar la a 1 y al restar la
a 1 encontraremos el área que nos
interesa vamos a hacer lo primero
encontraremos el puntaje z de 47.5
tomamos 47.5 y le restamos la media que
es 40 y nos da 7.5 cuántas desviaciones
estándar por encima de la media es esto
dividimos el resultado anterior entre la
desviación estándar que es 3 el esta 2.5
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media por lo que el puntaje z es 2.5
positivo si hubiera estado por debajo de
la media
sería un puntaje negativo dejamos
nuestra tabla zeta ya hemos hecho esto
en vídeos anteriores lo que hacemos es
ver esta columna izquierda que nos da el
puntaje z hasta las décimas y estas
otras columnas nos dan el puntaje hasta
las centésimas
buscamos 2.5 en esta columna a la
izquierda y como no tiene centésimas
buscamos punto 00 en estas otras
columnas movemos nuestra tabla z hasta
encontrar 2.5 aquí está 2.5 por lo que
nuestro valor estará en este renglón y
punto 00 que está en esta primera
columna por lo que 2.50 está aquí y
quizás se sientan tentados a decir que
esta es la proporción que se encuentra
por encima de la calificación de louis
pero no esta es la proporción que está
por debajo de la calificación de louis
lo que nos interesa es 1 - este valor
sacamos de nuevo la calculadora y a 1 le
restamos 0.9 1938
este número es la proporción que está
por debajo de la calificación de louis
al restar a uno este valor tendremos la
proporción que está por arriba de la
calificación de louis lo hacemos así
porque la tabla zeta nos da la
proporción que está por debajo de cierto
puntaje esto nos da cero puntos 0 062
esto como porcentaje sería 0.62 por
ciento de las calificaciones que son más
altas que la calificación de louis lo
que tiene sentido porque la calificación
de luís está dos y media desviaciones
estándar por encima de la media así que
nuestra respuesta es 0 puntos 0 0 62 la
proporción de las calificaciones que
están por arriba de la calificación de
louis